>>> It's just heartbreaking to
see what happened to him.
I'm broken-hearted.
I've been crying for the last
few days knowing he's no longer
here to share all of his
inspiration and his prayers and
everything with us.
>> That was a grieving
parishioners talking about how
the death of a catholic bishop
has affected her and her
community.
David O'Connell was shot and
killed over the weekend at his
home near Los Angeles.
Authorities have a man in
custody, and they say the
attacker knew him.
>> The person of interest was
identified as Carlos Medina, the
husband of bishop O'Connell's
housekeeper.
>> Let's go to CNN's Josh
Campbell who is live in los
Angeles up and early this
morning.
Josh, what more are you learning
about what happened here?
I know there are so many people
heartbroken that this bishop has
been killed.
>> Reporter: Sarah, good morning
to you.
65-year-old Carlos Medina was
arrested yesterday by a los
Angeles sheriff's department
tactical team after an hours'
long standoff.
Authorities say bishop David
O'Connell who was renowned for
his work as a community piece
maker was found dead Saturday in
his home.
A deacon went to check on him
after the bishop was late for a
meeting.
The unidentified person told
police that Medina had been
acting strange and made comments
about the bishop owing him
money.
Detectives were also able to
gather surveillance footage near
the crime scene which showed an
SUV pushing into the driveway
and departing later.
The motive right now is unclear
and although there have been
reports of some type of
financial dispute, Luna said his
investigators have not yet drawn
any conclusions.
>> I'm not here telling you it's
a dispute over money yet.
It's something we've heard to
this point and it's something
the detectives will go out and
validate and see if it's true or
not.
Based on what I know at this
time, the suspect had been at
the bishop's house before doing
work.
So there was some kind of a --
maybe a working relationship,
but we're still trying to figure
out what that relationship was.
>> Reporter: Medina has not yet
been charged.
CNN is attempting to identify
whether he has an attorney.
You and I have covered so many
of these murder cases where you
often hear from a family member
or neighbor saying, yeah, this
was a troubled person, they had
a criminal past.
We're hearing from numbers who
say they were stunned that this
man has been implicated in this
murder.
One telling kcal that Medina
was, quote, your average
grandpa.
As investigators work to peace
together what happened here and
why, community members of all
faiths in L.A. And across the